hey folks hanging out the parking lot
given this beautiful 68 caddy a little
bit of a polish before our next episode
a backseat driver this belongs to Dave
Ramsey friend and country music
superstar Shawn Ridge who so kindly let
us borrow this great car for our guests
today because our episode has a special
Nashville theme tune hey thanks for
doing this man all right John Rich's
caddy well I would expect nothing less
than this car from mr. John Rich in the
back seat today is Charles esten the
talented actor and singer plays Deacon
Claybourne on ABC's popular series
Nashville when he's not on set Eston is
performing his hit single hot one all
across America well chip you and I have
a Virginia connection growing up in
Virginia you're in high school at TC
Williams high school that's the famous
high school from Remember the Titans did
you play football I did play football
for a couple years there I was a
quarterback I was not first during at
any point in my career there I was
between second and third so I did some
talent shows back then didn't really get
to do any plays because I was in the
sports and making music and then after
college it was am I gonna go do this
music thing or do I do I follow the
acting this thing I might like to do I
had a couple friends that had already
gone out to LA so I went out and started
first time I ever saw you professionally
was on whose line is it anyway how soon
did you get into the actual improv work
from that time after college it's not
like you can just go be on a TV show so
well you can do is you can go to an open
mic night and just do stand-up I got off
there and I did it I remember the nerves
I was petrified it struck me instantly
the moment I got off the stage I thought
to myself
really this is what you want to do and
yet you're gonna let yourself be
paralyzed by 200 not quite sober people
that you're never gonna see again
somehow I've walked through a door of
that understanding of what fear in that
instance really is from there I'll fast
forward to where I ended up in London
about a year or two later somebody told
me about this British television show
called whose line is it anyway so I
first got on the British version how
important is it for all of us to kind of
step into that fear is that's powered
you through I'm sure so many situations
in life I'm gonna go way back to
something that I did that I thought it
was pretty pivotal to it that I got a
manager rather early but they didn't
really know me so I invited them to
dinner my wife and I did and basically
showed off for a couple of hours one of
the things I did was grab a guitar play
a little music they had no idea I could
even do that they gave me a call saying
there's this role of Buddy Holly would
you like to audition to play Buddy Holly
in London and I was like yes that is
that is what we're talking about now and
somehow I got that role and I ended up
doing that for a little over two years
changed my life it set us up a little
bit financially early on it got me on
whose line I got to where the thing I
was trying to learn acting well I got to
do the thing I knew which was playing
music performing live on stage so what
you just said is a life lesson it's
exactly right a thing I wanted to do is
a living I got to learn to do while I
was doing the thing that I was really
good at Wow and that's yester class
stuff right there
well find a way to make that happen I
mean I didn't I didn't aim for that girl
you know what I need to do right I need
to learn what I want or a lot of people
know you from the office were you a fan
of that show was a huge fan of the
office in fact I'd watched the British
one first and so I was a little dubious
if I'm gonna be on honest until I saw
that they had Steve Carell and then they
also saw that they had my friend Rainn
Wilson who I'd done a pilot with and I
said you know what I think they're gonna
be all right
right after I did my audition it went
pretty well and and they said so I
understand you know rain I said I'm more
than no right now
a pilot with him where we played
androids who solved crimes and they all
kind of laughed like you didn't I said
I'll tell you what if you give me this
job on my first day of the work I will
bring that DVD of rain were little bonus
I think by the time I got to the parking
lot I got the call from my agent that I
had the job I'm a really good rolls the
one you really want I always figured you
know what I don't I might only get one
opportunity to play Deacon Claybourne
ever in my life so I'm gonna enjoy it
I'm gonna make the most of it for me it
sort of feels like a real book end to
the Buddy Holly thing it really does I
was sold at the name Deacon Claybourne
it is a great name you know come man
whose eyes are set high and is trying to
be forgiven and find that grace and all
those things like a deacon but then his
last name is Claybourne born of the clay
like earthly infallible that has to be a
really positive thing for you when you
lay your head on a pillow at night that
there's this derivative that's positive
of your art does that happen a lot
absolutely I understand the side door
that I've been blessed to step through
when others have earned it a much more
legitimate way some would say well dude
here we are the Ryman yep unbelievable I
gotta ask you what was the feeling like
the first time you knew you were gonna
play it here like you someone kills you
obviously couldn't believe it to tell
you the truth because none of this is
lost on me I understand what this place
is at some other Church of country music
this is hallowed ground for a musician
isn't it and after the stage is so
iconic I have got to ask you what's on
your top three greatest songs oh that I
always find that it seems so hard no
it's I mean but hey nobody said life for
this interview was fair right right
then just one I know I'll say that that
number of moves constantly course at any
given way at any given time I will I
will say Hank Williams I heard the story
when I was a little boy of Hank Williams
coming out on this very stage right
there nobody knew him and then he broke
into his now-famous lovesick blues and
he hit that first yodel and everybody in
every seat of this building stood up on
their feet and went crazy because of
what the
resonated out of where it came from and
they couldn't get him off the stage
there were at least eight curtain calls
that songs always had a very special
place in my heart take us to that first
moment when you walked out from those
curtains back there onto this stage for
a live audience well you know I kept
thinking about all the things and all
the people that have performed here Hank
Williams Roy Acuff Patsy Cline they
don't need any of the politics of the
mind games these people are so very
talented that affords them the
opportunity that they take to be
extremely kind so that combination of
the best players in the world and
completely welcoming that's the only way
I was able to do anything at all little
Jimmy Dickens passed away a couple of
years ago and he was 93 when I met him I
believe he made me feel welcome and if
he makes you feel welcome there who can
say otherwise and then that amazing band
behind you means you just step forward
and focus on the one thing which is
singing your song telling your story and
that's what I love about country music
is that the story is primary I think
that's why it goes so great with our
show there's something that music can do
in a place that maybe just words alone
can't as for my character he's that
classic cowboy that doesn't want to talk
too much or say too much but you hand
him a guitar and he gets behind that and
he'll they'll spill everything I just
hang out here
by the way visit this place is
unbelievable
it really is yeah what's your big idea
my big idea is we got John Rich's
convertible caddy let's just cruise
Nashville you down let's do it let's
take this roof down thanks John rich you
mind if I ride up front I do not mind
soon my boys and I climb in and drive
down the mine holes fine I can feel the
temperature